looking for some pretty chilly changes
blowing in
in about 48 hours or so so if you've
been ready for some fall weather
then get those jackets and sweaters
ready to go got some haze out there you
can see that again
mostly light winds had some breezes out
there this morning on the west side now
i talked about
6 55 as the sunrise in a week
not this weekend but a week from
saturday night is when you need to set
your clocks back
as we'll fall back to standard time and
you get that extra
hour of sleep we all benefit from more
sleep so
especially it keeps your immune system
going and just
you know keeps your definitely your
system up and
better prepared for flu and cold season
and boy we're already getting into it
aren't we
lots of 50s out there this morning upper
50s is normal
otherwise we've got some low 60s but boy
these numbers are going to fall
maybe 15 to 20 degrees for morning lows
by next week that's right
so you need the warmer jackets and the
warmer sweaters
plus we're going to have winds to deal
with sunday into monday as well to make
it feel
even cooler now redrock election day
coming up november 3rd that's also the
date that you're going to need
time of day reservations to get into red
rock so if you enjoy the scenic loop
hiking and biking just going even out
for a picnic you're going to have to
make an
online reservation for day and time to
come out there so
please make sure you're doing that go to
the website for red rock all right we've
got
cold air across the plains moving over
into the midwest
snow across the rockies and then cold
air
also from a large storm system dropping
out of the pacific northwest
we're going to get a taste of both of
those and we've already got
freeze watches for outlying areas
outside of las vegas
for monday night into tuesday morning so
far it's a freeze watch we might wind up
with wind advisories
for much of southern nevada too over the
weekend as we are looking for some gusty
winds
ahead of that approaching system today
winds shouldn't be too bad
we're looking at warm conditions mid 80s
breezy southwest winds tomorrow
downright windy on sunday with that
approaching cold front
and it will push through some moisture
we have a chance of showers around the
valley
sunday night snow in the mountains and
look how much colder
we go from 79 to 59 for a daytime high
on monday
59 overnight lows look at 40 tuesday
morning
to 43 wednesday morning it's going to
take a while to rebound but we'll get
mid to upper 70s back
next week wow that's a chilly change
nate